the only thing you should be thinking
about is if everything was perfect like
as if i was a genie from the future and
can grant your actual wish you have to
try to make that actually happen meaning
if you've said to your own self that i
want to be an actress or i want to be a
doctor whatever that is that's what 22
to 30 is about it's all high risk some
questions um well so
i like that i got into it because um i
was finally diagnosed with anxiety and
depression about eight years ago okay um
and it helped me a lot and then the farm
bill was passed yep and then you started
seeing cbd everywhere yeah of course
i've always been a long time cannabis
enthusiast
so i always knew i wanted to work with
the plant yep um the void in that a lot
of people do not know how to consume
properly and that's why i started my
company
um they also don't know what to look for
in a product
so i that's why i do the curation
um
and recently with new york being passed
for cannabis i wanted to open a
dispensary
did you apply for a license
i can i and i had a business partner and
up until two months ago we just stopped
because she didn't have enough runway
yeah
as do i yeah i get it she had her own
cbd plan
and so
it was also an obnoxiously competitive
process
you know
those licenses are worth a trillion
dollars exactly and that's why we
decided to stop i get it and it makes
sense
it was hard to let go because it was
like my lifelong dream but i now realize
with two kids also
quality of life
yeah retail sucks like for quality of
life like it's i it's still my favorite
business like
but
it is definitely not the quality of life
business retail's a challenge no
question the good news is you're still a
young woman and
like over the next 20 30 years
the way licenses and locations and
states open up they'll
if that's an itch of a lifelong dream
that you have it will only get
progressively easier
uh for you to achieve that uh
it depends you know it may require you
in 20 years moving to a state where
there's unlimited licenses
but it's real i mean for example new
jersey
you own your liquor license and you can
only have two
new york
you don't own it you just apply for it
and everyone has one
so like it'll be interesting to see
which states do what over the next 10 15
20 years but you know as hard as it was
to get in new york right now this time
inevitably in 12 years
it'll be the easiest thing of all time
in pennsylvania or ohio or new york or
new jersey or today
so keep that in back your mind keep
going and um also um
so i'm trying to get onto the thc
cannabis side while sustaining my
company which sells
predominantly cbd
and what about the service itself the
service itself i offer consultations
people book online yep and what i do is
walk them through the basics such as how
does it work
is it a free consultation right now it's
a free consultation and i know i'm
supposed to monetize on that it's not
necessarily it's back to even some of
the like you know yes and you know what
i mean there is no right per se answer
there's
a couple different ways to think about
it but keep going
so it's so the model is free
and then you're hoping to in essence
sell product to make up the margin that
has a lot of friction in it that's like
a high propensity of like
drop off of like the you know a getting
them even into the funnel b now you're
giving them the content
and then see you need to require them to
buy and just making the margin on so you
know it's that's i that makes a lot of
sense to me of like the challenge in
that
yes so and that's where you're at i
assume yes that's where i'm at um also i
don't want to monetize because it's hard
enough to
have people understand they actually
need to be educated on it
um right you didn't want to create
friction of cost right
so um that's where i am at now and just
trying to see where i can fit in within
the cannabis industry have you thought
about
and so how are you producing content if
at all um just on instagram and being
very careful
using certain words yep and how has that
been going um so recently i did a real
and then that was good so i have to do
more reels um
probably have to get on tick tock too
um i think my problem is because i'm
wearing all the hats i'm a solo printer
yep trying to get content while doing
everything else
on top of
kids is a little challenging no question
what about the volume of consultations
that you're doing what does it look like
uh it depends how much i network with
mom groups uh women's groups
so give me a sense
the last three months
this is how many you've been doing per
day or week or month probably twice a
week okay yeah and i repeat customers or
hopefully seo
which is
recently very bad
it was working for you a little bit and
now not as much because google's always
changing
is that what you're saying well that and
also the person helping me with seo
there
um they had covered their so
kind of their company kind of uh
disappeared yeah
was it working
i would say about last year and ever
since then they we've been having
trouble since then
how long was there a period where you
would consider it working and what was
the dynamics of that meaning how long
was it working and how much traffic were
you generating or leads were you
generating based on seo from your
opinion
and it's okay if you don't know the
exact detail i'm just trying to
calibrate it was probably last year for
about 4 months
6 000 a month
and
then it dropped off
end of
november
did you feel the impact of that 6 000
visitors a month you were getting leads
from it yeah
and where are you at with facebook
groups
mom groups
more instagram
not um
have what about the concept of
building your personal brand through
employment or sponsorship of a brand
are you open to that or no
i am open to it um i just didn't want to
see i was pushing one brand because i
have about 15 different brands
and i
feel that they all have a reason to be
there when i do my curation that makes
sense products for women's health issues
makes sense
for
anxiety
based on the numbers i'm hearing it's
when is it not viable
at this point it's still small yeah
and like when can you not afford to like
do it
okay
a week ago yeah
you know that's that's why i'm going to
the brand side so where let me let me
recap now now that i've asked some
questions
the thing that the reason i asked about
the brand side is
you gotta it's kind of like you gotta
fly the plane while you fix it right so
there's a couple things that are running
through my mind one when i hear those
kind of numbers and the business model
i'm like oh [ __ ] she's not making any
money
right
and so
okay
one
what do we do about that because i don't
know savings or how you're doing all of
this right but i know that even when
people have savings losing money each
month eventually plays itself out
so
there's either
the the expertise that you sit with in
your mind is your is your value
what you know and how you communicate it
is your value prop
you being a platform to
curate for humans to come in for
consulting and being completely agnostic
to product
is exactly right
it's the admiral thing to do and it's
the best way you can help someone the
biggest issue with
medicine in america is it's a business
and people aren't doing that so i love
that that's the best what i'm concerned
about is
you don't have a viable way to like
sustain and do the best for people
so where my brain goes is a couple
things one
couple things you have no shot to do
what you're doing now unless you go 360
on your content output okay right like
even the thought of like the sentence of
i did a reel makes me want to jump out
the window you know what i mean like
even when i heard it my skin was like
that's the worst ever you know because
that's because that lends itself to
and and by the way i'm incredibly
empathetic and very much understand
kids the consultations like i get it but
it's a it's a chicken and egg game
unless you produce content at grand
scale that it's your number one two
three four five six seven eight nine
content over consultation for a year
is how you could actually pull this off
if you decided to keep going about it
the way you're doing it
there is no shot without it it is the
oxygen and the driver
right
so a couple things on that let's we'll
put that we'll we'll go through that
path first because it helps everybody
here including yourself and then we'll
go into a more is that even viable but
let me let let me attack that right now
so
the biggest elephant in the room and
this is going to be a big aha for
everybody including the sasha group
because they're about to hear it from me
as well
as is every vayner x company
yesterday in a morning meeting me and my
team made the decision
that instagram is now the fifth most
important platform for my personal brand
going from number one
that's like dramatic
so
when you are a solopreneur especially in
cannabis where you can't run ads on
these platforms
you must win on organic
forget about the fact that you have to
be incredibly careful with cannabis
because the organic can be taken down
and the account could be banned so we'll
put that on the side for now but we'll
get back to that in a second
for
for you to succeed
you have to think about first of all you
need a pillar piece of content so you
have to either have a show or a podcast
you actually can't
survive in the model you have for now
without it because even if i get you to
do what i want you to do which is to win
on
get ready now everyone facebook
tick tock youtube shorts linkedin and
instagram
if i want to get you to win on facebook
youtube shorts and tick tock you could
be banned on all three platforms you
could amass 150 000 followers on each
and then have it taken down because of
the pl and everybody in cannabis is mad
at the platforms i'm not this is this is
government right federal regulation
they're not they want your money
facebook is very interested in every
cannabis companies you know meadows will
take every cannabis company's dollars
for ads it's that they can't
when the government
wins blow left or right or indifferent
what can't be taken away from you is
your podcast
so
you have to have a show
where you give
where you interview people
right
you know where you just talk
if you look at the garyvee audio one of
the things that crushes people with
shows is the production they think they
got to put on a big it's like it's when
i say that for a lot of people and maybe
including yourself right now it's like
[ __ ] that's like a lot it really isn't
it can be as easy as taking your iphone
hitting record and talking
if you look at my podcast that's what it
is as a matter of fact the number one
comment about my podcast is the sound
quality because it's all over the place
it could be from anything like i'm not
making a podcast i'm making audio that
happens to go on my podcast and
sometimes it's a one hour 30 minute
keynote that i gave in sweden and next
time it's a four minute 10 second clip
from a piece of social media ripped
audio
right
i think you need to think about that
first of all that if that your personal
brand is your business
right if you think about how i built how
he was just talking like you have to
start there
you can't be in like seo sales or get
into you're in sales mode and i need you
to be in brand mode
seo is subconscious sales it's intent
marketing i want to buy it's sales right
um
going
networking is sales
it's more sales than brand what i want
you to do is put out all the brilliance
in your mind
into the ether
and then having that be the gateway drug
pun intended to the opportunity for you
to do business
got it like i want your accounts to be
tight and you putting out tons of
content random thoughts random like if
again if you look at something that i
want to do more of that i did for a
couple weeks i tested it earlier this
summer it's like my morning walk talk it
was literally
whatever was on my mind camera post
right and it was very very strong and
performed quite well thank you um can
you take this one this was a sad effort
by me um
you're gonna have to do that
the reason i bring up in young people is
for a lot of people
it's hard to come up with so much new
stuff to talk about and i'm empathetic
to that
which is why i always tell people to
interview people because then you just
say what's your problem i mean it's what
you do for a living what you do for a
living is ask a series of questions
hoping they give you the most honest
answers so that you can then prescribe
to the best your knowledge right
half your battle is to get them to break
down their walls to give you insights to
get to the good stuff right
i think i think you have to really go
there if you don't go there
it's i don't think it's viable i don't
think you're gonna get there and then
you're gonna have to do something else
financially which gets me to why i asked
you is it okay to potentially one of
these 15 brands for you to be a brand
ambassador for a little piece of time to
collect some more savings so you can run
them in parallel one of those 15 brands
especially you know one of the great
things about conscious brands
is they're either fully full of [ __ ] or
not and what i mean by that is
not that they're full of [ __ ] it's that
they care about their issue they care
about their bio picture they clean stuff
but they might not like what i love
about the world right now is everyone's
chosen they're one or two things to be
awesome about and a great human and
altruistic but but then are oftentimes
not awesome about other parts of the
world
i'm curious of these 15 brands which one
of them would be thrilled for you to be
a brand ambassador for them but also
because they're good human beings be
okay with you building your own personal
brand and sometimes recommending not
their brands my belief is that 12 of
them would be like go [ __ ] yourself i'm
not going to let you
promote my competitors product because
they're not altruistic on that point of
view of like humanity they are in a
different way but three of them would be
and of those three maybe now all of a
sudden you get a 50 000 a year
consulting gig to be a face for them but
you don't have to compromise what you do
on the side and that cash flow over time
lets you if you do what i told you in
the first part you can eventually at
some point leave that and go back to
this
right like i think one of the things
that people really struggle with in this
exact moment is the theoretical mental
step backwards to keep going they'd
rather like just go out of business
i always i always
find that fascinating that they'd rather
see this because you're doing it
yourself i'm a solopreneur
and just do it until it dies and go get
a job versus coming up with like one
step backwards on the way they see it
it's not an actual step backwards it's a
one step backwards on the way they see
it
and so i'm trying to get you to like
look at it from a different angle that
might allow you to keep having oxygen to
achieve your goal
okay but this will stop and start with
your ability to produce content
period
that's going to be it for everybody
otherwise there's a million of you
like when i go to hall of flowers
in la i met 37 of you in two seconds in
the green room i want to consult people
on what mix of product they should use
i'm like that's right it's called
doctors like it's right it's very right
but you're gonna have to compete with
everybody for attention and the only way
to do that is content
and
well so my second thought was while
trying to keep this viable
um
looking for something on the side
that'll help with
meeting more people in the cannabis
industry
i'm just trying to see where i fit in
like a job yeah well great i mean i can
help you with that you should definitely
email me we'll set that up um i have a
lot of relationships in that world i
where do you live
would you move
my kids i get it i get it i'm not i'm
not saying that lightly by the way would
you move
um i might have to wait a few years yep
so
there's so much opportunity in
california
and like i'm tr you know i have a 10 and
13 year old like i don't think that was
a lightweight question but it's
something i definitely want you to sleep
on okay because
we'll set up this email i will introduce
you to four or five people in the next
couple weeks
one of them may lead to an opportunity
it's going to be highly likely it's
going to be in california
but to your point new york's exploding
the first person i'm going to introduce
you to is one by name of joanne wilson
real champion of women
her and her husband fred wilson is one
of the most successful vcs in new york
history um
she got one of the licenses
in california
yeah she'll be the one that i most hope
works out for you because you don't have
to move and she is the greatest champion
of female entrepreneurs and is overly
passionate in this space
so
we'll make some intros
you're welcome
all right i think we're ready to move on
i love your outfit joe kim
hey gary nice to meet you pleasure how
are things
thank you for allowing me to join this
way and hi guys hey kim
right now gary you have no idea kim
right now like gonna burst out of her
seat and if the word learning gasm comes
out
i'm wondering what
foot view would you say you have of
vaynermedia and how close do you ever
descend to being surface level and
working in the business
i think that i am
uh
and it's fun because a lot of people are
sitting around me right now who've been
with me for a long time i think what i
do is don't play in the middle
so the answer to your question is one
inch or a hundred thousand miles
i try to stay out of the middle um i'm
i'm very i you and my team is constantly
always like spooked by
some of the details i know on a
day-to-day and then obviously my job as
a ceo is to be up in the clouds and
watch how it all works and make sure i
know where i'm taking it so
to answer your question one inch and a
million miles it's all about for me not
being in the middle which is where i
find a lot of executives uh find
themselves and so
um i also try to think about a mix of
what do i like and what i'm what am i
good at right
so
um
that has a lot to do with where i find
myself i find myself in places that are
either
i like it and like what the [ __ ] are we
all doing here i'm not i don't think
maximizing money is why i'm an
entrepreneur it's maximizing happiness
and so if i like it
it's kind of like speaking speaking is
something that i
really shouldn't be doing at this point
in my life even though the fee the
speaking fee i get is one of the biggest
in the world and like every day i book a
speaking fee i immediately stop for one
second and like laugh with myself that i
cannot believe i'm getting paid to speak
for an hour more than i got paid the
first six years of my career working
every day
and yet i still shouldn't do it but the
only reason i do it is because i
genuinely like it
like it's fun like i like the feeling
it's like being a performer right you
like it uh
same as the way i think about being a
ceo i go into things that i like or
things that i'm disproportionately
better at than the majority of the
people in my company and so that's how i
find myself in different places
i'm not overly worried about
micromanaging or being you know what i
never want to be is an ivory tower
that's tone-deaf one of the things
here's another interesting insight there
the reason garyvee the brand really
actually exists is and if you look at
the history of my content when i stopped
doing the wine thing in 2011 there's
really not a lot of content in 2012 and
13 and even 14
because i was building vaynermedia i was
back to what i really am and always m
which is an operator and an
entrepreneur it was that in 14 i started
to sense for the first time that i
wasn't close enough to the work
the social media content and the media
spend and it was the first time i found
myself saying wait a minute like when i
started vayner9
everything i was doing it all for wine
library and for myself so it was easy
for me to tell pepsi and campbell's and
the nhl what to do in 14 i
i was still doing it but i felt for the
first time that i was 90
not 110
and so i said [ __ ] the only way this is
going to work is if i build my brand and
i do it every day like i did with wine
library tv and that's when i started the
askgaryvee show and that's really when
what what everyone sees today about
garyvee started that moment when steve
unwin and and drock and indy like when
we started that whole thing and so
um
i stay like one of the things i'm most
proud of is i'm ready for a debate
around media and creative with every
single person that works at vayner x
because i'm so close to it so in the
craft of what we do for a living like
the product we sell
i'm the closest
but in the fact of like
you know james and i had a 15-minute
meeting yesterday to catch up on
business which is the first time we
talked in two months about it or like
like he's running it he's running sasha
like i'm not in it i'm there i'm
backbone
but so
not the middle is the answer
you just said you're looking forward to
a debate or you're waiting for the
debate
what side would you take
on what you mean social media overall
what i meant in my analogy was somebody
talking about like what works on
linkedin right this second from a media
or creative standpoint or or how do you
get virality on a youtube short right
this second my strength in that game is
ridiculous for somebody who is a ceo of
a company
as far as the overall debate i'm i'm
massively pro social media everybody who
shits on social media for political and
social issues isn't realizing these are
empty vessels
the hyperbole around what facebook does
is based in complete false cities and
people have to become accountable like
i've seen
i've seen bad things on regular
television and in print and in the
streets of the world and i haven't
decided that watching people be racist
made me a racist you know like i think
we have to become very accountable to
our actions and it's very convenient to
blame social media
cool
you got it thank you so much kim we'll
talk soon okay
bye-bye
all right so now we've got uh 25 minutes
glenn and team so these guys are going
to have you with some questions
and i'm going to try to save like three
or four minutes at the end of that
because glenn also has a question about
another entrepreneur endeavor he wants
to ask you awesome yeah uh as a true
entrepreneur he's got a lot of ideas i
love it
you know when i did the your your self
brand whatever was called back
you had an exercise that i tell every
young
entrepreneur orthodontist that because i
was told me 20 years ago right i'm 54
in the land of entrepreneurship or
modern-day i'm an old fart right but
screw that i don't care i get a lot of
time ahead of me and i'm just like can
um
but i remember 20 years ago i learned
and i did it once and then you reminded
me to do it again which was reach out to
10 people from different parts of your
life and ask them
what's your biggest
strength weakness i kept the spreadsheet
and the same thing kept popping up over
and over again impulsivity
and so now i consciously go out of my
way to not be impulsive right so though
as a purebred entrepreneur it's also
your strength exactly when your gift is
your curse it becomes understanding how
to tame the animal not to eliminate it
right so i stay in the area where i'm in
by the way 4ds this moment
was an impulse moment remember
i was in the room
like i have goosebumps because you just
talked about like that little exchange
means a lot to me we're in the meta of
an
impulse moment around cash flow
and the bit like it just you can't like
it's your biggest strength
i went live
like
like but keep going but the point is i
stay in where i am in
i parking lot the idea
and i ruminate on it an hour a week a
month and the idea is talking about
something to put on my head for two
three years so i'll get to that at the
end i love that i'm a big fan of where
there's smoke there's fire i do the same
thing but don't become so ideological
about that that you're not willing to
occasionally go from impulse to action
because that's what this was they will
tell you never worry about that
[Laughter]
slow down the impulsiveness yeah and of
course at the end just like two minutes
remember i brought my daughter in when
she was graduating high school she
didn't listen to our advice of course
we're on the podcast she ended up going
to arizona graduated magna [ __ ] laude you
know communications and now she's living
here in new york working at riven as an
independent awesome and her life is
about she's leaving her every now and
then for interviews for her
next job makes sense so um i wanted to
give her two three minutes awesome to
ask a question
i sat at dinner with her my cousin uh
started a company called eden just got
some really good funding he lives here
and they're talking back and forth about
stuff i've never even heard of about
program sat app software
you're going to be more plugged in way
more plugged in than i'll ever be
awesome i want to give you just a couple
of minutes at the end i hope so so i've
got one
big problem yep nobody can solve okay uh
i figured throw it your way yes but i'm
going to ask you just a couple of
smaller questions really fast you got it
um
short form content joe is thrown out to
me you know i my podcast i've done for
four and a half years i do my friday
five minute friday i've done i did my
blog i mean i'm just throwing out tons
of content but joe told me about two
weeks ago short form vertical 60 seconds
or less youtube
two three four times a day i started
throwing it out my question for you is
on across youtube oh it's not youtube
across my podcast it's video
with audio my videos posted on youtube
my audio's thrown up on in full form in
full form yeah well you know
full form but like the quick
so both the whole thing and then the
post production
so
i've got the video and i've got the
audio videos on youtube the audio is
hosted on buzzsprout which then goes out
to all the platforms yep
i get a sense like the video
isn't getting me the traction that the
audio did okay audio only so when i post
it when i throw it out there on ig
linkedin wherever i'm throwing my stuff
would you post the the video which gives
you that beautiful thumbnail and then
here's the audio only version which is
what i've been doing or do you say screw
the video side of it let youtube
search handle that
and i just throw out the audio only
version which was good for me for a
while remember i'm in a small pond so
that's question one well that's that
there's a lot there first of all the
first answer is both
you literally post them both
you literally post
in big letters audio only and then you
post the next
six hours later with the video in your
video
like you do not the same post the same
po
you can because you said six hours later
yeah the same well ones that you said
should i put out the audio or should i
put out the video i'm putting i'm
putting the video which gives me the
thumbnail and in that post here's the
audio only version yeah i understand
okay yeah that's exactly and by the way
you don't need to put the link to the
video because you could just take a
screenshot from any moment you liked and
then just post the audio link
so he's saying you can have a hero image
that correctly plays as the audio
players got it so you can have two
pieces right that's right and then you
can have that that's right
but i think you you subconsciously or
consciously got to the more important
part of course it worked more upfront
you were just getting your penetration
to your pond
that you were just starting to fish this
new pond you've eaten a lot of [ __ ]
fish out of that pond and because your
thing is so narrow which is great
because i love narrow depth well there's
only so many fish in there right right
so now what ends up happening is you've
got to start creating micro strategies
for example
what is the content you're making for
the kids that are in school to become
ortho right right that's going to be
very different content than someone
who's 17 years into their career and is
trying to maximize their
profits or their lifestyle or are
transitioning so what you've got to now
do is
micro segment
the pond right right which is what i
started doing good i really started
focusing
much more on the residents because my
demo is orthos are out of school
you know a year to 12 years give or take
ages 30 to 42 43 that's like my demo yep
but
most people when was the average
orthodontist is coming out of residency
with five six eight hundred thousand in
debt yeah right and so
getting them ahead of the curve and
going okay guys you guys get into school
soon let me teach you how to hit the
ground running let me show you like i
know what you're living and what you yes
comma what you can also start doing and
this is where you can widen your world
you could be talking to them while
they're in the process
of collecting the debt and what could
they potentially be doing right
and that's where the narrative sort of
switched at this point of the game and
again the last question is again i don't
want to take too much time this isn't
the big problem but
it's hard
do i chase like what i talk to
orthodontists about i can talk to
anybody in this room about it's the same
stuff you talk about 100 percent the
culture the hustle the the plan right
the the team you should absolutely start
flirting with broader content 100
it needs to be part of your mix it's
hard you know to serve both masters but
are you kidding me the first 50 pieces
of business content i made every comment
was [ __ ] you stay in your lane wine boy
the [ __ ] do you know about business i'm
like jesus christ i was like that's all
i've been doing i just became wine guy
to you because of youtube i'm like i am
business you know so
yeah you'll get some of that you'll
probably less because it's not as big of
a jump for you because you've been
talking about the business support
though um you should absolutely mix it
up
my shorts have been focused on but you
need to be
insane
insane about facebook fan page output
number one
the game is back at scale that's where i
live
so facebook fan page number one youtube
shorts number two tick tock number three
you must dominate those three arbitrages
how many pieces of content like a day
would you say ideal for per platform per
platform yeah
on those and then there's twitter and
instagram and regular youtube and link
and linkedin so i can do content
creation that's what i love doing
and content creation is more about
post-production than actually your time
it really is if i've got if i've got
which again i'm working purposely to
make sure that i've got those moments
those times where you can take pieces
and show them out later on like that's
right like you talked about it right
close every time that's right right and
so um
the last little one which it may not be
that little but i i don't think it's
huge is it's been on my mind for at
least three years now
um and listening to you talk a lot about
the culture the social consciousness of
a company i feel like i have to do this
like this is like keep me up at night
but i'm afraid of the resources it's
going to take is i've been trying for
three years in my head
to create something called embracing our
warriors
where too many ptsd
injured hurt vets come back
and the va doesn't take care of them
they want they deserve a smile they
deserve to feel good when they look in
the mirror
and i've been talking to the va i've
been talking to the non-profit folks
about developing because i've got the
sponsors or companies that
create ortho brands i've got the doctors
all over the country that's right um
to be able to build this non-profit
where a vet can be vetted
like legit like they are a disabled vet
and them and their family can find a doc
that we hook them up with who will get
free product from the company so just uh
just crawl
just get it started
yeah you know when you're winning
in one part
it makes a lot of sense because you're
playing at this scale over here that it
feels natural to get this thing over
here to be at that same scale
immediately
and i think you know the resources is a
real thing
but i think
what you do is you just decide today
that you're going to do it for 25 people
you're going to
alpha test it out with a brand or brands
with a couple of doc like a doctors or
when you get the applicants you'll just
bubble gum and tape it one by one you'll
call ronnie or sally and be like this
guy's in minnesota will you do like you
just alpha it i got i got the contacts
just hey yeah because what you're trying
to do rightfully i get it you're trying
to come from here and push it down like
here's the platform this is what we do
and then you're boiling the ocean and
this is what you get into this moment
instead
do it behind the scenes
as bubble gum and tape get the taste of
it and then scale it right up yeah i can
do it from within
it's the biggest reason content doesn't
work i alluded to it when i was talking
about a show can just be clicked but
everybody
everybody biggest mistake is they try to
make it too big and it's all in their
head and they never do anything
they just go this way yeah just start
doing best way to do this we call 25 of
my friends tell them to post in their
communities hey anybody know anybody
that's reads and then i connect them to
the sponsors and get it done
you've got a big enough platform that
you just say here's the google for you
make one google form you make one video
you send people and then you see what
state they're in and then you reach out
to the people you air traffic control
because then you're more in control
great idea nice you got it so here's the
big one and i brought this one
legitimately to dozen i worked with a
guy named todd brown uh who's really
brilliant guy helped us a lot but
i don't know if you know it's hot or
hurting i don't think guys that's
awesome offers that's good
nobody can solve this so i've got a
group called orthopedist rd a regional
dominant stupid name i made it five
years ago but nonetheless it's a group
of about 195 google and nike are stupid
names
why are they not yes names are just
proxies names are made so garyvee with
two silent e's is a stupid name
on the record
two silent e's is a bad idea
men well i think
jordan oh sorry
it's good
no we'll i'll make it work on the back
end don't worry go ahead i'll make it
super quick please um just moved out
here for an internship i'm 22.
still not quite sure what my end goal is
i get asked what's your five-year goal i
want to figure out not by me clearly yes
maybe i'm too crappy
i guess my question is if you were in
knowing what you know now what would you
say to your 22 year old self because
i've been throwing some darts trying to
see which one sticks but i'd just love
to hear from you
my if i gave you the actual answer it's
so complicated because at 22 the only
thing i wanted to do was build my
family's business for them
and i was kind of like the talks i was
having were weird which is like you're
gonna give up the best years of your
life for your parents because they did
it for you and like i had like this
altruistic like noble like family
immigrant vision and i was psychotic
about it like literally did not like
like actively tell people like i went to
everything is best in balance like it
would have been okay if i went to the
jersey shore once in my 20s
it would have been okay but i didn't
that's how psychotic i was i think but
there the reason i'm so happy is because
i'm going to give you the answer of what
ties that together which is
the only thing you should be thinking
about is if everything was perfect
like as if i was a genie from the future
and can grant your actual wish you have
to try to make that actually happen
meaning even if you've never said to
your dad only to yourself not even your
best friend like if you've said to your
own self
that i want to be an actress or i want
to be a doctor or i want to
be a supreme court justice or an
entrepreneur whatever that is whatever
it actually is
that's what 22 to 30 is about
it's all high risk it's the biggest
[ __ ] falsity that has been sold to
kids now you've got to actually know
what the [ __ ] you're doing
as if
you're actually in the best position
ever to execute
something that's not practical
you don't need a lot of money to live
you can live with 40 of your [ __ ]
friends let alone three you could
you can eat like [ __ ] in your 20s so you
can buy dollar food and like you can
just you don't have kids you don't have
you don't oops sorry uh you know you are
you are in the most practical place from
22 to 30 to do crazy ass [ __ ] but the
world has taught kids that that's the
time you're supposed to have it figured
out it's insane
so my advice to you is
whatever your biggest single dreams are
that you've kept to yourself have been
scared to even think you could you've
got to challenge yourself to try and
that looks like this
whatever i just said if it is supreme
court justice it's interning it's paying
a law firm even though you didn't go to
law school to like be an assistant like
people understand how life actually
works like if you could just get into
the game weird things happen
right if it is hollywood life like you
need to move to la and like [ __ ] like
work for like it's working for free
which comes in all shapes and sizes your
dad is a successful business person you
might be able to afford to work free and
that's okay that's like family dynamics
work for free is also working at say
ryan reynolds worked at safeway that's
working for free that's nine bucks an
hour like you know that's the that's the
theory right like it's zero if you're
miraculously in that situation most
people aren't some are it's okay my kids
will be for example it's okay
or minimum wage but in the thing
or
a shitty job that gives you plenty of
hours to be in the thing i tell a lot of
people who want to be influencers to get
like a job at 7 11 and just make content
all day while they're standing behind
the register
like you know like get a job that's not
actually making you do anything so they
have time to do the thing that's true
i mean
i don't want to think what people are
doing right now that i'm paying them you
know like
you know like so you have to go for your
actual dream the one that scares you the
most because it's the one you want the
most but you haven't even thought you
had a chance to do it that makes sense
it actually makes sense this is what why
i'm so passionate about it
if not now when
but but the world really [ __ ]
everybody up like this concept that you
have to now you went to college and you
thus now know what the [ __ ] you want to
do who show of course certain ironically
orthodontic doctor yes of course there
are a small group of professions that
the passion in the school and you know
for everybody else
nobody's doing the [ __ ] thing what
and that's where everybody is and and
you guys have know your options you have
so many options because of technology
but the real answer to your question is
the dream that you haven't even
felt comfortable believing in
i love that
thank you you're welcome
and julian why don't you go ahead and
introduce
yeah sorry about that no worries but i
definitely want to say thank you for
taking the time happy to do it
to me happy to do it this is amazing
it's fun um so yeah uh so my name is
julian um founder and ceo of momento
entity i've been in crypto since about
2012. yeah your homie has been giving me
the i got that contacts yeah um so we
help celebrities influencers and
athletes um turn their short form video
content into nfgs instantly from their
phone got it so the content is the nft
yes and the person that buys that nft
owns the content or does not and then
number two does it have a utility so
all three good so they own the content
right so if i am a
housewife
that's on tv in there's obviously i
there's the version of i get paid
through cameo and i make it hey sally
happy birthday that's one thing but
you're saying if i'm a housewife
uh and i make any piece of content like
reviewing a glass of wine instead of
putting it on instagram which is for
brand building and awareness i can put
on this platform and if one of my fans
wants to buy it
they can right okay and that gives them
the commercial usage rights of it so
that's that's what we're working towards
but you're not there yet right yeah
that's
there's a lot to that which is why i'm
poking yeah keep go so right now because
you're not fully there and you'd like to
be there but you need some clarities of
law and a lot of other stuff and sign
off right now it still sits as a
collectible which is okay i've i've
spent billions on
not really but like a lot of money on
collectibles so it's at this point it's
still a collectible plus if you're able
to negotiate with them to put a utility
behind it so we do have utility yep so
the template we sort of negotiate with
all
talent is with uh utility so we do
anything from live streams to tickets
passes love it merchandise is really
huge that sells really well
and so all that comes together it's
really like so what i was telling your
team last night was there really hasn't
been a like
huge phenomenal uh fandom web 2 platform
so we're kind of like leapfrogging
fandom from
you know traditional meet and greets at
the mall to the 1900 numbers right to
web3 now it's it's
i mean you saw how i structured v
friends it's my entire belief of
the what people underst the reason
hasn't happened is
the blockchain's technology as you know
enables this in a way that the internet
didn't
i fully agree it's much more direct it's
around ownership
yeah you just know who owns the asset at
all times and you can't do that on the
internet
and you can't make a royalty on those
transactions yeah
people are very confused about the
consumer blockchain they don't realize
that it is enabling certain things that
the internet couldn't the way the
internet enabled certain things that the
real world couldn't
yeah right now everybody's into the
greed moment and we obviously know where
we're at right now with nft pricing and
where we are in the crypto moment but
that will be four seconds or four months
or even four years but the inevitable is
the inevitable so what's the question
because i really understand um so right
now i'm really just hyper focused on
building a brand
right
have you been able in when did it launch
uh so we watched it three months ago
okay good so it like you've been in a
bear market pretty much the majority i
mean i'm sure it was it didn't seem good
at the time but actually it is so you
don't have the problem of people buying
them with the thought that it was going
to be worth a lot of money uh so week
one and two yeah got it kind of pivoted
yeah all right because the idea then was
a
big one of ones right and we sort of
pivoted to
uh higher volume lower price point yeah
what you should spend 100 of your energy
on comms wise and marketing wise and and
energy wise is
utility with the collectibility being a
nice to have if it happens
because then you won't get into what's
probably happening with that small group
in your discord now which is they're mad
at you at what the value of the price is
sure
yeah i feel like for us that's that that
that is a position right like you're a
fan of someone
i want a ticket from them i want a live
stream with them that is what um
inherited
at the base of that it is the it is the
client as the c as the cmo it is your
number one job it's my number one job
the number one job of the next 36 months
is to get everyone to understand
everything you guys all thought about
with nfts was always the second you know
the reason i made unlimited i'm sure you
saw it unlimited videos that 99 of these
things are going to zero
was because
the collectible part was the nice to
have sprinkle it's about the utility
which is why v friends was 100 v con
for three years from day one
my timing was better for collectibility
which was bad i like was anxious all
last year
i was like these things i don't want
them to be 200 000 a piece yet
maybe in 30 years if i accomplish
everything i want um so this is great
but this is what you have to be you have
to be
the company that over educates of like
let us tell you what the blockchain's
meant to do
it's meant to have this be
you know uh clickable affirmable that's
the key to it i just clipped the david
letterman
uh bill gates
interview from 1995 that i'm putting out
on my social
uh asap and
bill gates is like this internet to
letterman you know
i listen to a ballgame
on the internet and let him the big joke
letterman's like have you heard about
the radio and the whole crowd laughs and
that's what's happening now people are
like
well if they were watching this right if
we were live stream right now all the
comments would be like but you don't
need an nft for that you can get an
email confirmation or you can use a qr
code or a paper ticket you could
but this technology will enable a lot
more things than those things do just
like the internet did a lot more you
could listen on the radio but when we
when you listen five years later from
that clip i was because i did so much
fantasy baseball i was listening to
games on my laptop and trying to trade
players and seeing the visual and like
you know there's and and and and that's
that's what you're gonna have to make
everyone educated sure
you could buy a cameo but in nine years
if you still own that little funny will
ferrell video from our platform we may
say all will ferrell
owners tonight 20 of you have dinner
with will because we can affirm who has
it that's what the technology does
yeah and for us what we're we're really
trying to like that honed into is like
those collegiate athletes those up and
coming up-and-coming tick-tockers right
who knows three four five years from now
they're gonna be like the next big
celebrity and if you bought it early
you just need to make sure that you talk
even hearing that sentence from you make
sure you always say
you're it's what i if you look back at
how i position v friends which is why
it's why it worked for the people that
bought it first obviously then it got so
valuable people bought at a different
price point which put which i can't
control but if you look at the early
thing i'm like i'm pricing this in the
way that i see v-cons worth as a
three-year ticket
if there's collectible value that's
added bonus and that's why that original
group was so happy
you've got to make sure
that you go that route because then
you'll have a much healthier community
and company
you're buying the access the utility
you also have the collectible as added
value and if god willing
you know you this person goes on to be
the most famous actor in the world maybe
there's a collectible that
you've got to do that otherwise you will
get
what you're
you've already got it i haven't looked
then i know yeah because i know the
market
and so one of the biggest problems that
i sort of think about i'm not sure if
it's a problem i guess it's just the
nature of the industry but
because we deal with a lot of
celebrities right we work with their
talent managers
um so there's a significant amount of
sort of pay for play
what are you seeing in the sentiment of
like
not brands but much more of the
celebrities themselves wanting to
interact with nfts
celebrities are transactional
celebrities life the majority of them
this is why a rock or a ryan reynolds
you know
uh
like or or even like what reese
witherspoon and like gwyneth paltrow if
you look like there's just a very small
group that thinks non-transactional and
by the way
with respect to everyone
usually you have to get to a level of
wealth
that allows you to not think
transactional what do i think they're
transactional
i i love uh
like i i was having a meeting with a
very thoughtful uh
individual who's been very successful um
and he was talking about like we have to
do music festivals where the artists
finally get taken care of i'm like they
did get taken care of they got paid
eight million dollars to play that set
and then they left
they were more than welcome to take two
million dollars and get a piece of the
gate
celebrities are transactional
everything they think about is how do i
make the most out of this one moment
which is why they've had such a tough
time in nft land
they're not there for the long game
it's it's why i get like a lot of
misjudgment because too many people
think i'm celebrity i'm like i'm not i'm
business man i'm building this thing
like you know like it's
i think you're gonna have a massive
challenge with anybody who's even got a
half a level of fame
they're only thinking about the
short-term bag yeah they're not thinking
about anything else that's their
business they rent out their fame at the
moment of the fame
i don't blame them i don't think you're
going after pee wee herman
but guess what 15 years ago he could
have gotten 500 you know i mean like
that's just the game that's the business
they're in they're in the business of
like when i'm the most famous i need to
take as much off the table as possible
unless they have an entrepreneurial part
then they can get more thoughtful let me
build a brand but most of them don't
which is fine and normal like most
people aren't entrepreneurs
so
that's different than emerging tick tock
players and you know and that that crew
is seeing the world differently they all
think they're entrepreneurs
and a lot of them are willing to
negotiate differently
i think what you need to do
is not waste your time convincing
what i would do if i was your third
partner i would say here's our offer
it's sharp as [ __ ] this is it
and if they're if they start hemming and
hung we're like this is the only thing
we can do
and we just take who says yes and
instead of wasting our time with uta or
caa or this celebrity or whomever
trying to spend all that energy of going
into these people let's just take who
comes to us and over time more people
come to us
that's the biggest mistake people the
biggest mistake people make when they
are doing business with people that make
the call is they spend time trying to
commence
the number one reason i think i build
massive scale is i have zero interest in
convincing anyone i've shut down three
minutes into a business pitch
i
i i'm not i don't want to be rude you
know it's been weird as i've gotten more
popular i'm even more conscious that i
don't want to be rude because i don't
want to think anybody that i'm big
timing you i'll sit through the meeting
but my brain shut off three minutes in
when i'm like they're out
because i have nothing in me and not
because i've been sick even when i was a
kid trying to sell wine
if someone's not if someone's out
they're out that energy for me to try to
get them in is not interesting i'd
rather take that energy and build
leverage with someone else or do the
thing that will make them in
convincing is the worst game in the
world and it's the game the majority of
people in business play
uh and by the way cool right yeah man
and he convinced his regret
by the way we do have a third person
spot if you
i wish i had time for [ __ ] i'm so and as
you can imagine i'm i'm actually in a
really shitty spot in nft land i'm
scared to buy anything
i'm in such a place in nft land where
people like see me buy one piece and
they're like gary you have to drive this
project make me money i'm like [ __ ] you
i bought a little thing i just wanted to
look at it i'm not the [ __ ] ceo
of like you know like i'm in a [ __ ] spot
i'm in a very [ __ ] spot which sucks like
you know it was funny i was really into
sports cards i am really into sports
going like next week i'm going to
atlantic city for the sports card
convention
but
you know
people started like making up [ __ ] about
me like he bought all these like and i
was like this sucks which is why the nft
thing was like amazing i'm like oh my
god i could do my collectible thing and
it's all transparent everybody will see
that i don't pump and dump that i buy
and i hold right
and that's been great that has worked
for me they can see everything i've done
that's been huge
but then a different bad thing happened
you know like now it's like if i buy
anything i'm like responsible which is
like insane because everyone's in greed
mode which is what you're feeling with
the people like
they didn't buy it because they believe
in you or that they bought it because
they thought they were going to buy and
flip it
you need to make sure that you take all
that math out of your math mouth excuse
me just make it about this is about the
utility with the potential it's utility
with a hint of collectibility
um so just
just two more things um so we definitely
are trying to engage the creator economy
yeah right so eighty percent we
anticipate are gonna be creators yeah
gen z yep uh and then twenty percent
sort of yeah makes sense
um hire somebody at mid at like back to
ironically one of the biggest dreams of
a lot of 18 to 22 year olds is to play
in creator land like you know you're
just living this so you know this to be
true almost all of them
from 15 to 22
either want to be
the
celebrity on social or be in it manager
supporter pr so your ability to hire at
minimum wage of like really talented 18
to 25 year olds because their job is
gonna be to dm creators on tick tock and
get like that's like i would scale the
[ __ ] out of that
and and by the way
in america it's minimum wages like i'm
looking a lot at la tam like back to the
way i want to give uh i had another big
breakthrough on this theory of like i
don't want to give to not that i don't
want to give to the american heart
association but i want to give to
you know a friend of mine you know that
has a problem uh
similar to how i'm thinking a lot about
scaling low-cost scalable jobs
i'd love to you know in in america
like i believe getting a job at vayner
in entry social is like the greatest
gift of all time because if they sit
here for two or three years they're
gonna leverage that for the rest of
their career
if we're if we're a penny below market
i'm getting murdered in the press for
being like you're a [ __ ]
savage trying to hurt like you know it's
very very and i'm so socially liberal so
i'm empathetic to it but it's very hard
and new york laws and l.a laws are
impossible like it's getting really
actually hard right
so
then i'm like wait a minute i can pay
people in argentina
half
but they'll be rich
like rich in argentina and so like why
do i have a bigger emotion to somebody
here than so i'm trying to figure out
ways so back to the point you could be a
good person it might just not happen to
somebody in america it might happen to
somebody in colombia or somewhere else
and get people that could do this i mean
you're literally asking people
to do robotic work it's the modern day
entry-level um
manufacturer that's exactly right it's
the modern day like a lot you know we
now demonize what happened in the 40s
and 50s but it's how a lot of people
bought their homes right like they
didn't have any other skill they're like
i can do this task
what's crazy is the kids actually can do
a ton of things they just want to do it
for a year or two because it's their
favorite thing they want to dm the
people they think are hot or funny or
cool or they just if they get a thrill
from it and all of us would have too
like if i think back and be like at 22 i
could have worked at the nfl and reached
out to football players and i'm like
i'll pay you you know like you know so
i think that's how you build that you
have to build scale on it so you have to
do that because most of them say no so
you need to dm a billion people yeah so
q1 of next year we're planning on doing
uh so we're calling it creator beast
right we just want to appeal to
youtubers to talkers
people in the creator economy here in
the east coast that's cool what do you
think about like a physical i love it
i love physical
i just think that
dming
at scale
is going to do more of what you're
trying to achieve with the dmming at
scale will give you the the width
creator east will give you the depth
like even right now like on our
instagram like you know it doesn't
happen like crazy amounts but we do get
dms like if no one's like actually
replying to them or looking at this
frequently you know there's missed
opportunity there so you need a point
every company needs to realize they have
to build a triangle and most don't fast
enough meaning a triangle organization
has a lot more people at the entry level
fee to create scale
when you start a company it's usually
like founders like it's like two three
four serious people up here like one
junior person it needs to be the reverse
it's almost like you need like four
junior people for every like
senior person and like what a lot of
entrepreneurs make a mistake on they
start with you two and the third person
you hire is also 150k like a like a dog
she or he is awesome what you needed to
do was hire four 30s
because [ __ ] needs to get done
[Music]